[Applause]
[Music]
she wants to be fair she wants to have
lots and lots of my name sir about the
time she wanna be free like Nelson
Mandela can polish a pyramid so she'd
rather be poor Ghana
there's no place you'd rather be
[Music]
she
I wanna be remembered
I wanna go Tony story I make my mama
proud the darker the berry the sweeter I
do not see talking you my love
no please sadder honor
No
I live and die now
[Music]
live a night
I
good afternoon ladies and gentlemen it's
a pleasure and honor to be here today on
stage is the group called sulci so we
met we have a couple of people played in
the audience to make some noise for us
the four of us met in high school
fifteen years ago and at the time you're
famous for singing boys to men covers
because they were our biggest
inspiration and I remember in a very
purview a in my room I had a Mariah
Carey poster and Britney Spears poster
too and I can't help but feel that times
have changed because what used to be
mine I carry in my room now in a 15 year
old boys room is tiwa savage what used
to be 50 cent in my room it been to a 15
year old boys room now is Southie so on
and the role of alpha beats in
emancipating and getting over the
colonial mindset of the youth cannot be
ignored
after beats has played the strongest row
so far if you ask me as far as
motivating the youth is concerned we are
now the superstars of our generation for
our people we have the solution to their
musical problems and people our age and
a longer looking for entertainment from
America from the West
we are the entertainment and the priming
us above any other form of art in 2015
President Obama came to Kenya and we had
the pleasure of being the entertainment
for the state dinner that happened a
citizen ROV and as we were performing he
jumped onstage with us and together we
did a cultural dance to a song that I
want to share with you guys right now
and wherever you are if you feel the
music dance ladies and gentlemen Surya
[Applause]
[Music]
my
we mama
[Music]
thank you thank you so much
so alpha bees Afridi's appropriate ease
of force it's a force in the world right
now just last year in the last year
alone Africa had songs in the Billboard
charts one one dance
written by wizkid performed by wizkid
and Drake unforgettable French Montana
for those who know or don't know
French Montana is Moroccan artists who
the world has normally considered as
mainstream and now realizing they're
late to the party and they're knocking
on the door and because we're good
people we're gonna let them in when you
look at an artist's queen bee herself in
brackets Beyonce Beyonce has used Oh
Beyonce has African influence in her
music a couple of years ago in 2011
through YouTube she saw this dance is
called tougher tougher dances from
Mozambique and she flew them over fall
away from Mozambique till Los Angeles to
teach her and her dances they're now
signature dance moves that you see in
her song who run the world girls yeah so
with social media and a vibrant vibrant
African diaspora more and more the world
is dancing to our rhythm and talking our
pigeon yeah thanks Nydia will use that
for cost award yeah our next song calico
jana had a viral video that was posted
by Snoop Dogg Neo Talib Kweli
and the general feedback of this song
especially in the black community in the
United States was that this song gave
them a feeling or sense of spiritual
repatriation so ladies and gentlemen
cool accordion
[Music]
ha ha
yes
[Music]
[Applause]
we okay
[Music]
let alone
Oh
[Music]
[Applause]